kanye west is definitively taking the
most unpopular risky positions you could
take in today's hip-hop culture
regardless of where you line up for
people who've been living under a rock
have you listened to the recent kanye
album the the gospel the christian album
have you been following his recent sort
of conversion to christianity what's
your reaction to it genuinely and i want
to hear from you let me know before you
respond are you a Christian are you an
atheist because we've been seeing a lot
of responses from the left from the
right from people who you think might
support them from people who you think
would be in tagging istic it's been
pretty surprising and hopefully this
helps you sort it out so for those who
don't know obviously opened the weekend
with his album Jesus as king I think
it's good yeah and it's an entirely
Christian album and he explained it to
Jimmy Kimmel for those who missed it we
have Christian innovation and our time
that there was a time when the Medici
family and all the greatest artists did
work for the church and now it seems
like all the best designs and everything
have this adult edge to it
how much one about he just learned who
Medici was yeah yo listen I want to use
the word Medici yeah on that but no I'm
going to be fair here there's been some
controversy or the release he asked
those participating in the recording
actually to not engage in premarital sex
and he himself this is one thing that I
will say is is definitely a positive
thing he went on to talk about the
negative impact that that pornography
had on his life and even it even spoke
out against abortion yeah Democrats had
his boat and Democrats with food stamps
for years bro what are you talking about
guns in the 80s taking the father's out
the home Plan B lowering our boats
making us on board our children gosh and
not kill
I can't tell y'all how to feel but what
I can tell you honestly is how I feel
no the interviews like mmm yes there's
nothing deep there's like I can tell you
my opinion yes and pre-chewed there been
a wide range of reactions harvest
obviously have some on the left they
want to effectively cancel Kanye West
for this overtly created message but
then you have some conservatives on the
right
who've been celebrating him as this sort
of figurehead and then you have some
other people who've been trashing him
some people have just been kind of
cautious as they were after his
pro-trump tweets let me tell you one
thing because I've mentioned that I
think this takes balls because Kanye
West has something to lose so we'll get
into some details here as far as what
the recent transition has been but
eliminating potty-mouth in basically
condemning premarital sex not exactly
super popular in the hip-hop community
we're saying well you're generalizing I
want you to look at Billboard Top 100
pick any song from the hip-hop community
and pick any of those artists and see
where they would line up on those that
being said I'm not jumping on a
bandwagon people I've always been a fan
of hip-hop we're gonna show you to be in
the radio five six years ago four years
the very last segment the bump was all
the lights from Kanye West we've done
multiple parodies of Kanye West we've
always talked about how I think he in
the past I've thought that he acts like
a jackass but the guy is a brilliant
emcee he's very talented here is
something I want to get out of the way
first I do think there's some danger in
exalting and sort of this hero worship
of people who are our new Christian yeah
so I want to make sure that nobody does
that that being said the reason I'm
saying that is because I want to see
someone like Kanye West to Kanye West
develop in his I sound like him Kanye
West II I want him to develop on the
spiritual journey I think there can be a
lot even if you're not a Christian you
can have a huge positive impact I just
don't want to see someone who is not
equipped to do this yet thrust forward
as a mouthpiece it'd be like tossing an
amateur to the pros and it was at this
the album it's pretty it's pretty good
it's not his best album certainly not as
worst and it's certainly comparable with
all his other albums that would be
considered you know more sec I was
worried about it yes jesus loves me yeah
yes I know why Connie cuz the Bible
tells me so I think we're seeing a
genuine conversion experience here and
again we don't want to thrust someone
into the spotlight and yeah give them I
guess we don't want to turn them into an
authority figure
but we'd certainly I don't I don't like
it when I see Christians or
conservatives saying like oh well now he
wants to change all listen that's why
every way yes in here that's why you
need Jesus Jesus because we're all a
work in progress and if someone doesn't
feel as a
can come out with their their faith
publicly without being attacked from all
sides it's just going to discourage
people all around something else I think
that's pretty um interesting here he's
expressed not only his Christian faith
which is different from a lot of people
who say I'm a Christian later in life in
Hollywood and it's sort of agape God is
love and it's the trees all around us
yeah he's talked about rejecting the
leftist atheist ideology that dominates
his industry the entertainment insurer
which i think is ballsy I told him I
said look my my father's a black panther
my mother got arrested for the sit-ins
at age six certainly they were fighting
for us to have the right to our opinion
Jackson right to stay for ever the white
liberals said black people are supposed
to vote for ya so I think this is
important because the guy is definitely
going sort of if we talk about sort of
Kurt Kurt Cobain who hated conservatives
back in the day right but he was sort of
in this you know he was Steven this this
nihilism right in this sort of overall
negativity and hopelessness
do you think he would have still
supported the left if he saw them today
being the anti-free speech sort of
authoritarian that they are at least
Konya has the balls to point that out
and i think there are two important
points here as it relates to his sort of
coming out if you will right now before
we get is Christian he's living at a
statistic that we've talked about on
this show it's undeniable as people age
as they they get older they gain more
life experience they always become more
conservative and this is regardless of
socioeconomic status even across races
though it still is is comparable it's it
you're talking about it in a relative
way black people still are
overwhelmingly Democrat but they become
more conservative as they get older
individual policies people get married
they become more conservative they have
kids they become more conservative they
pay taxes they become more conservative
the only place where it doesn't happen
ironically is the entertainment industry
because it's this weird time warp let us
see what child they never grow up it
stunts their growth that's point one you
can come in in a second point number two
often we see celebrities come out as
born-again Christians we know this is
Christians like
the bender where their choice was do so
much below that you would end up in a
ditch and being a tabloid or accept
Jesus right and it usually come or or
some form of religion yeah but it's
usually accompanied by some level of
insanity like think Lindsay Lohan with a
jab and like with Kanye West we're
seeing the opposite someone who's been
known for being kind of crazy and he's
actually lucid right now ADA to
articulate his beliefs he seems to be
coming more humble like we're seeing a
new and improved Kanye which is the
exact reversal of what you often see
with people who are new convert and for
an industry that's this sort of
hell-bent on this idea of tolerance and
forgiveness it is ironic to see them
rejecting a guy who really isn't going
out there being judgmental he's offering
free Sunday services and he's still
doing what he's always done with his
albums by the way hit the notification
bell just bookmark the YouTube page if
you're here because notifications don't
always work new video every single day
at 8 o'clock 9 o'clock Eastern I always
forget the taint time came at the time
because playing the game yeah another
point here I think it's sort of people
have missed out on here's what how I
would describe this okay and forgive me
I know I am a Christian but I'm a very
flawed Christian so I know people say
well your question you about to use this
non you warden yeah parallel I use an
audio words in Kanye West we're seeing
the unmasking of Kanye West but right
before our eyes
we're gonna turn that into a verb he's
proper word remember the VMAs when Kanye
stole the mic from Taylor Swift who can
forget this I'm really happy for you I'm
let you finish but Beyonce had one of
the best videos of all time
holiday awkward
I said it it doesn't behoove us to say
that he was anything other than a
jackass red he was a jackass very much
but more recently he seems to be more
humble seems to be more grounded and I
think this is kind of an interesting
study because he of Taylor Swift now
coming out as Pro lgp LGBTQA AI PC I
forget the acronym you just you slipping
to the hole abortion anti Trump and
anyone who disagrees with her she lumps
into the category of hater right these
people are hateful she's turned into the
sort of this eagle maniac that Kanye
used to be Taylor Swift has never met a
safe position that she didn't like again
Kanye West is holding himself out there
right now Taylor Swift when she was
doing country music right back in the
day it was it was teardrops on my guitar
was vanilla it was Romeo and Julia it
was small-town America singing in the
country Church only when she decided to
move over to pop and she has her lesbian
cutted chain gang from BuzzFeed and
HBO's girls that she decided that she
was going to be Pro LGBTQ which by the
way can only help you in your career
compare that with Kanye who was in the
hip hop community where he's banning
potty mouth and you shouldn't do drugs
and have premarital sex Taylor Swift has
always taken the position that would
benefit her when she was in country or
when she's in pop Kanye West is
definitively taking the most unpopular
risky positions you could take in
today's hip-hop culture
regardless of where you line up I have
to respect that now I'll not doggie pile
on someone for doing that speaking which
actually um I think do we have another
clip yeah he was asked Kanye if he's
afraid that he'll be canceled because of
his specifically the Christian album I
liked his response are you afraid of
losing your audience yay I told you
there's an edit yep that's different
god I'm 15 years I'm telling you God is
showing that you can have your own
thoughts bro
I've been cancelled before it was
canceled culture because without Jesus
even Reese's can't go with pieces of all
these Christian rhymes so this group you
need to be a little more breathy though
yes here's I love by the way for people
who don't know that edit like we were
talking about this he wasn't necessarily
edited out of context yeah but this is a
common editing technique that that to me
is is
so insidious because people don't even
see it if you interview someone and you
ask them a question here yeah and then
the answer here and they start talking
and they get more passionate and then
they start talking up here but you ended
it so you asked your question here and
then you go back to him bro talking like
this about Jesus
it looks like he's crazy that's clearly
not where he answered that question um
the thing is though his Christianity
doesn't seem to have hurt the album
sales it's probably going to debut at
number one and what does that show us it
shows us there's a disconnect yet again
between critics and fans the people in
the music industry like we saw with with
knock down the walls a hundred percent
net a hundred percent negative a citizen
came on on Rotten Tomatoes and then fans
can't stand it yeah we're seeing this
now with with critics and people saying
oh there's a real risk well it's not a
risk with fans and I think this mirrors
a lot like like Jordan Peterson is it
right yeah there's kind of a definitive
these sort of boundaries that are
established in academia right it's
completely dominated just like with
hip-hop there are certain expectations
and then they say I'm keepin it real oh
come on you weren't shot 19 times in the
face and you don't have gold rims I do
drive at 50 with windows because you
don't wanna be recognized not all of
them but there isn't because their
expectations right and Jordan Peterson
was in an industry I guess for lack of a
better word academia will call it an
industry dominated by liberal post
modernist yeah and all of a sudden
Jordan Peters just one reasonable
professor comes along and suddenly his
videos have millions of views yeah
professors would have told you that that
can't work right you can't go up against
the grain you can't be someone who's
more conservative or preaching I don't
want to label my conservative preaching
an individualistic point of view
preaching to pull yourself up by your
bootstraps that you can actually control
your own you can't do that and just
upload it randomly to YouTube and expect
to do well well turns out people
actually want it to Matt improve their
lives and telling them instead of
telling them that they were a victim of
patriarchy and that they should dye
their hair pink and wear a [ __ ] hat
similarly Kanye's album seems like it's
filling a cultural need and I know
jailed
a is going to disagree with me on this
wait most Christian there's been
Christian music around for a lot oh I
know where you're going yeah it's it's
mostly pretty bad because it's mostly
Christian bands mimicking secular bands
and it has like a niche market for fur i
play this game on the radio
called is it a Christian it's just
called Christian radio car game as we
call it and when my wife and I we travel
to a new state or we're in a rental car
we hit scan on the radio and I only have
three seconds to guess if it's a
Christian radio station I have like a 96
percent success rate let's understand
because either if the word you fountain
oh yeah solace or rescuer or if they
have that breath all of us yeah or the
girls who kind of sound like Lord but
not really that's like there's a sound
right crappy and it's trying to use
sometimes a marketing gimmick and this I
think shows us something right now his
album is doing really well yeah right
and it's in it's an all Christian album
it's a gospel album it means that a lot
of people like myself I have every
county at Ulm ever they like Kanye West
for his music in spite of some of the
graphic content or maybe the cultural
content they didn't agree with that was
me with Kanye West and so I think where
as critics thought oh they like Kanye
because of these sort of subversive
words in this this adult to use Kanye's
term content no people liked him for his
music in spite of that and I think that
this is going to um create a bit of a
reversal in the minds of a lot of
executives I think it's a healthy thing
and this is one thing I was talking with
someone actually at a church recently
about this this morning and this is one
thing that's always bothered me it's why
we do this this show okay like I'm not
holding myself out as an example for
Christianity it I'm very open about my
faith I think everyone here is but you
have sort of two worlds with a lot of
Christians they go to church and then
everything is everything looks nice
right everything looks great and you
don't hear any naughty language at all
and people sort of talk about their
trials and tribulations but it's in a
very sanitized way and then they got
into the world and then they sort of
feel it but they just sort of engage in
the filth right right they kind of have
that choice and I don't think that that
really I think it's doing a great
disservice to a lot of people I think
especially for Kanye West to come out
and talk about porn here's the truth I
think anyone under the age of 30
probably 99% of men have struggled with
pornography or some kind of sexual ask
you because it's not the same as drugs
like I don't need to it's pumped into my
phone like I don't need to rat on a
surgical tubing around in a belt and
freebase it's just like oh let me check
my email
yeah yeah or every billboard or every
story that you walk by in the hall you
know right and that's one thing when you
go to church you have a lot of
Christians who go up and like the Lord
freed me from heroin like oh what a
wonderful story like the Lord freed me
from violence I was an ms-13 it's like
great but then when the conversation
gets to the sexual problems that a lot
of people have because everyone people
get really really quiet
Kanye West promoted this sort of
cultural debauchery right he was out
there he listened to his albums their
x-rated some of them particularly if you
listen to this one bit with Chris Rock
and his Journal saying easy taught me
came over the track but was um what's
that one the red red album has all the
lights and has a twisted fantasy my My
Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy wow
that's a mouthful yeah I want it to be
extra long so people when they go to
pronounce that there's no mistake huh he
promoted all of that for a long time and
now he's saying I was wrong about that
and still being forthcoming about that
there's real value in that and I'm not
saying some Christians just say I am
what I am no no no listen you should
change right so we even have sin
completely covered or hushed or people
feel ashamed to talk about it with
church or you go out into the world like
hip-hop or anyone entertainment ship
where it's glorified but you should be
able to talk about it with other
Christian yeah right not without
glorifying without praising it but
saying hey how do we come to a solution
but we don't so it's either complete
silence or glorification of sin and
Kanye promoted the culture for a long
time a lot of the time we don't really
understand this artists not only
sometimes create culture but they still
do live in the culture yeah they're a
byproduct of culture it's kind of like a
never-ending loop and so he was a
byproduct of culture she would he would
tell you he's talked about this and they
said and I promoted this it's almost
like a kid who's bullied at home so they
go and bully other people and he went
out he feels guilty about it and he said
I wish Monas I don't know how many kids
that corrupted whether you agree with
him or not now that he was corrupting
people I do to a certain extent and this
this is the whole reason that we need
Jesus in the first place some people are
further along the trail than others I
think as it relates to Kanye West I
always have to be respect to a guy who
has a balls to hang himself out there
and he
doing that I don't know how long lived
it will be I hope I hope it's a lifelong
journey
I think everyone out there you can be
apprehensive and you should be
apprehensive but also support the guy
because he's taking a risk a genuine
risk and he does need some support and I
think if you approach it that way it's a
balanced way
it's a healthful way to approach it it's
the way that we can most serve someone
who's new to sort of their spiritual
journey and no one is going to have egg
on their face for doing that ok
subscribe hit the notification bell
bookmark the page but most importantly
join my club it louder with credit comm
slash mug Club this is taken from a show
a life advice segment that's like 60
what is it sixty thousand minutes longer
no it's about 45 minutes longer but you
get a full show behind the paywall every
day that you don't get here on YouTube
because we've been you monetize a whole
long time ago and you know I don't
expect that to be fixed
[Laughter]